point
[Musique]
je t'ai vu en train de l'espionné
aujourd'hui non c'est pas ça
ok
[Musique]
demain est d'accord
c'est quoi ce bordel très
qui déménage en plein milieu de la nuit
il n'y a rien de bizarre elle comptait
partir en quoi ça vous semble étrange
j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi elle
n'en a pas parlé
telle qu'elle est dans contre vous elle
doit savoir que vous êtes pauvres et
vous devez le loyer
j'ai trouvé un genre de code comme un
message secret dans son appartement
ça veut dire qu'un de silence notre
monde regorge de code de messages
subliminaux de silverlake washington
tout ça peut avoir un lien avec ça je
connais cette ligne il y à un message
dans la musique tu vas trouver un
message caché dans une chanson crois je
sais pas ce qu'il ya derrière ne suis
pas loin de découvrir si on peut dire
est-ce pour présume que toutes ces
informations sont ce qu'on nous dit
qu'elles sont peut-être qu'il ya des
gens plus important qu'une plus puissant
qui échange de messages dans le monde
qui sont pour eux seuls pas pour nous
ouais bah tu trouves ça tendu un chouïa
[Musique]
bienvenue au purgatoire c'est bien
d'être là où vivait dans une fête
foraine en espérant gagner a appris
vaughan y aurait quoi
sous le lac argenté
[Musique]